typically the indie anglo-saxon mindset
there is hardly any rule for the
government you think the markets will do
all and if there's scarcity of resources
markets will react but this is wrong
because climate disasters happening
perhaps 50 years from now are not
visible on today's markets so you have
to have a state intervention or an
international agreement like the Kyoto
agreement making it more profitable for
companies to be climate-friendly then to
squander energy and one measure that we
have been taken in my own country at the
time when I was member of parliament was
the ecological tax reform which let
electricity and petrol prices rise in
small steps for five consecutive years
and at the same time was reducing
indirect labor costs and in balance it
was calculated that this saved or
created roughly 300,000 jobs for a small
country like Germany this is a lot
because labor getting cheaper meant that
for the employer it became more
profitable to lay off kilowatt hours and
hire people than the other way around so
this is a policy measure which worked
very well it was not exactly popular but
it was very good for the economy of
Germany and I suggest that America could
emulate that scheme but today it would
be so unpopular that I doubt it it was
going it will be adopted it soon
we can do five times better and that
relates to carbon efficiency but also to
metals water and energy in general so
what we are doing Oh considering is a
transport system that is based on very
efficient cars my friend Amory Lovins
talks about the hypercar or revolution
that would do something like hunted in
20 or 150 miles a gallon plus much
better public transport as we have it in
Japan or in most of Europe plus
technological advances in rapid public
transport again in France in Japan in
Germany we have those fabulous trains
which do roughly 250 kilometers per hour
and for practical purposes tend to be
faster than air transport because you
don't have those terrible waiting times
and security checks and all the rest so
that is the transport sector it also
relates of course to goods transport
walmart for instance is renewing their
fleet of lorries of trucks to be more
carbon efficient so it's a multitude of
factors in this one sector of transport
you could also look at agriculture where
water efficiency is perhaps the most
important part drip irrigation and and
all the rest but also energy plays a big
role and non-carbon greenhouse gases
play a big role in agriculture or the
housing sector my family and I are
living in a so called passive house
which is roughly 10 times more energy
efficient than conventional homes are
so we are saving a lot of energy have a
very good air quality and at the same
time do something for posterity for a
better climate